what's going on guys my name is David
Tomic and welcome back to the channel
today we're gonna be talking about
what's in your camp bag
2019 as a photographer videographer and
an entrepreneur there's a lot of
different things in my camera bag but
it's also a very minimalistic setup I
think you're gonna be surprised so let's
dive into it so if me personally if I
was watching this video from somebody
else the main thing that reaches me is
actually the camera bag I've looked at
so many different camera bags and try to
find the perfect one honestly this one
still isn't 100% perfect but it is one
of the best that I've owned so cloth it
is an in case 15-inch DSLR laptop pro
bag so I'm gonna try to link everything
down in the description below hopefully
it gives you some good links to where
you can find it and where you can
purchase it from at a good price but the
one of the reasons I love this bag
straight away is because everything's
accessed from the back so you never have
to be worried about anybody stealing
your stuff while you're traveling or
romy around it's always accessed from
the back a little bit in the menu at the
same time but it's fantastic one of the
perks of this one is it has a little
slot at the top where you can just grab
your camera out as well with no
hesitation and no delay but the real
reason this camera bag is a clear winner
for me over every other bag that's on
the market at the moment is because it
has a huge section at the front where
you can store one your laptop to extra
cause when you're traveling your jumper
tripod water bottle is anything you need
I can put my see my drawing stuff in
here
pretty much anything it's fantastic for
that reason alone so I think this bag it
isn't cheap actually somewhere around
200 mark but it is fantastic and it is a
hundred percent worth the price one of
the cons however is I have broad
shoulders personally and these straps
start to dig into my shoulders front
here when
gets a little bit too heavy I was
traveling a couple months ago and I had
all my camera gear in my bags and it was
just way too heavy I didn't go with a
minimalistic approach I took everything
thinking I need it all I didn't use half
of it to be honest but it was yet way
too heavy and definitely one of the
downsides of this bag now when I said I
have a minimalistic camera bag I really
do and most of the stuff that I use
inside this bag is actually set up on my
tripod right now so a lot of it I'm
going to try filming on my phone just to
give you a quick look what's actually
set up on the tripod and how I feel in
day to day but the first slide in here
will store my microphone it's also
something laughs what fantastic to go in
there
I've just got a vid mic Pro I bought a
secondhand off eBay for about $100 no
need to go grab a new one chances are
they're all going to be pretty good
condition because lots of people go out
buy a brand new hid mic and then never
use it so if you are just starting out
try find a secondhand one make sure it
looks in decent condition and go from
there that's definitely the number one
item in my camera bag moving on to what
I actually store inside my bag so I'm
not sure if you guys are gonna be able
to see this but almost nothing so inside
my camera bag we usually have the Canon
6d with a sixteen thirty five-millimeter
F 2.8 lens I recently sold two of my
other lenses to replace it with a 16 to
35 i had a 17 to 40 and a 24 to 105
however i found that i never used a
24-105 and the 17 to 40 with my go-to
everyday lens so it only made logical
sense of me to sell both of those two
lenses and upgrade to a much better lens
much better image quality and have a
better system all around at the top is
always my camera 6d with the lens on top
I always carry it around the lens hood
with me - I'd never used it but it's
always in the camera bag and it's good
to have look there's some some players
the second item in my camera bag is the
nifty pp so canons little 50 millimeter
f-18 lens it's
fantastic portrait lens and it's one of
my main lenses that I use Instagram and
Instagram marketing so this lens here is
going to give you incredible bokeh and
for about 110 used to 150 brand new it's
a pretty good deal
most of my images as I said are taken
with this lens when it comes to people
portraits and products as well because
you can get a little bit closer up and
use the macro feature on this lens the
next thing in my camera bag is the DJ
and have the gear now I've used the DJ
automatic air the pro the pro 2 the
phantom 3 for all of them but this
little guy is a hundred percent my
favourite he's so tiny and compact that
he fits basically anywhere into your bag
sometimes depending on what jumpers or
pants I'm wearing even in my pocket so
it's a great little light compact frame
that you can take anywhere that's a
fantastic item and always in my camera
bag because you never know when the
opportunity might arise where you might
need a drone and there's some fantastic
photos to be taken if you take a pretty
good look into my camera bag that's
about it my camera bag is almost empty I
try to travel as light as possible now
I've done their heavy routine before
where you take all your lenses and a wee
gear and it's just too hard but to recap
canon 6d 1635 new lens a 50mm lens as
well and DJI mad air that's it charge
cables extra batteries little bits and
pieces like that but nothing over the
top one thing I forgot to mention
because it's sitting on the floor I'm
not in my bag at the moment is the Joby
Gorillapod this is actually one of my
favorite tripods that I've owned to date
because you can literally mount it to
any surface and any positioning needed
to stand I've mounted her on telephone
pole with brick walls table legs chairs
anything in the gym it is a fantastic
little gorilla pod and it will hold for
a decent amount of time this one's only
about six months old at the moment so I
can't really give you my full review on
my full opinion on it but so far so good
and
definitely is worth investment
now there is one more thing that I carry
around most of the time that isn't in my
camera bag but to be honest it does fit
in my camera bag what I wanted to and
when I was talking about issues I was
having while traveling a few months ago
where they're hurting my shoulders it
was because it was in my camera bag and
weighing it down quite a lot and that's
the zillion crazy to do you don't know
what the zoom cranes doing it is a
stabilizing gimbal basically it's gonna
allow you to create very smooth and
accurate video footage for any purpose
that you need most of the time is used
for travel videos clients presentations
things like that but it's also used for
a lot of product marketing and digital
video recording there are a lot of other
gimbal options in the market at the
moment that are getting lighter smaller
and a lot cheaper as well which is a
fantastic thing especially for amateur
filmmakers gimbal started out in about
$20,000 apiece so now they come down to
under $1,000 some cases even less than
that for an amateur filmmaker to be able
to create professional content is great
for the industry
before I sign off on this video I want
to know something about you guys do you
use a DSLR or are you using your mobile
phone to take those Instagram bagans let
me know in the comments below and as
always smash that subscribe button
20-19 style and i'll see you in the next
one